hey what's up guys my name is Andrew ray
I make a youtube channel called binging
with babish and today I'm doing the
wired autocompletes
interview hey what's going on everybody
for the first week piece I'm Sean Evans
and this is hot ones it's the show
without questions and even hotter wings
[Music]
first one where does Andrew Rey live I
live here in sunny New York City I live
in so right now and I'm currently in the
terrifying netherworld where I just had
an offer accepted on a home that I
bought in Brooklyn but it's still on the
market so I'm just sitting here freaking
out the whole time during this interview
know that I'm just constantly freaking
out in the back of my mind about this
house anywho I live in Soho and
hopefully I'm about to live in Brooklyn
where does Andrew ray come from
I come from Rochester New York are you
from Rochester all right okay what's
your name sir I come from Cameron
Corey's hometown it's the birthplace of
such fallen Giants as Kodak and Xerox I
have a Kodak tattoo actually this is my
hometown pride tattoo a lot of people
think that this is apparently a symbol
from Dragon Ball Z I have not seen
Dragon Ball say so people would be like
oh sweet Dragon Ball Z tattoo I'll be
like thanks this is actually the
original Kodak logo from 1911 ekc
Eastman Kodak Company I saw that I
thought was so cool first of all that
logo like this existed in 1911 just wild
I wanted something that was a little bit
you know like a Rochester hometown pride
I also wanted a reminder to never get
caught in my ways and always be looking
forward I'm like Kodak where is Andrew
Ray's recipe I don't know what does that
mean where's Anna Rose recipe you can
find my recipes on any of my websites
Benji with babish comm basics with
babish comm that's probably what you're
asking but is it a recipe from me where
is my recipe for Who I am
I can't answer that for you bro where is
Andrew ray with hair
what like in an alternate universe or
something he's dead I killed them cuz he
was insecure cuz he was losing his hair
so next
how old is Andrew am 32 years of age as
of September 2nd of 2019 was born in
September 2nd of 1987 approximately 508
p.m. I don't know if that's true it's a
10 per second 1987 how tall was Andrew
red I'm 5 foot 9 on a good day is the
truth I I went to the doctor recently
and she said like okay you're five foot
seven I was like do it again and I stood
up real straight and I managed to squeak
out a 58.5 without shoes on so I wear
these boots that have like and they give
me a solid half an inch so I'm a
respectable height but you're only as
tall as you act remember that folks
how does Andrew Ray cook with pots and
pans with a knife
sometimes experimentally I'm very okay
with making mistakes and I'd take a make
a point of showing my mistakes on the
show cuz I want people to not be
discouraged when they make mistakes in
the kitchen to view them as the learning
experiences they are both in the kitchen
and in life this is way deeper question
than this person was anticipating how do
how does Andrew ray know the answer to
that is I don't I really don't know what
the you meant by that
how does Andrew Ray live it was like
this watched a few episodes I don't
remember them being this existential how
does Andrew ray live one day at a time
mother one day at a time figure it out
just like everybody else everybody's
everybody's just trying to figure it out
okay nobody knows what they're doing
everybody's trying to figure it out just
like you that's the best advice that I
ever got and that's not what that was
intended for I don't know what that was
but I hope that we glean some useful
information out of it can answer ray
this should be good can Andrew Rea age
yes as we speak I have gotten about five
years older looking so since we've been
sitting here can Andrew Rea read yeah
yep that's how I read that can't Andrew
Rafe wha I should have thinking like a
big bong rip before I did this I didn't
realize that these were gonna be so so
out there these questions can answer a
fly no I can't fly did somebody actually
ask that was it an actual search term
can Andrew ray fly what was it a typo
was it can Andrew R a podcast yes I can
I have a podcast called bedtime with
babish where I read like no good way to
describe this I always say where I read
adult bedtime stories and that always
sounds pornographic and what it really
is is Walt Whitman it's just like
grown-up things that grown-ups might
well doesn't do when they're falling
asleep what's next Andrew R a cookbook
yes so there's two of them Andrew R a
cookbook is available now two cookbooks
actually my first one is called eat what
you watch so it's more of a kind of
coffee table books of food from movies
and and it's some very pretty
photography recreating the actual scenes
from the movie it's cool my newer
cookbook the binging with babish
companion cookbook is the first hundred
recipes from the show and it is a must
have for any babish fan young girls
maybe not too young because there's some
profanity and drug use Andrew R a
restaurant one day one day I was
planning on opening a brew pub this year
but that has been delayed to 2021 cuz I
got some big stuff cooking some big
things coming out this year very excited
to share with you guys I can't share
with you just yet but keep an eye out
for it a restaurant or brew pub is very
much in the plans for 2021 Andrew ray
victory you've got damn right
did Andrew ray eat yes yes I did I had a
wholesome breakfast this morning
single fried egg with a ring of sriracha
around the yolk I wasn't even on camera
I just did it funds these two slices of
very thin bacon which so I felt like it
was okay two slices and a slice of whole
grain toast and then for lunch I just
had a freaking ostrich egg up in Bon
Appetit go check it out yeah
well we got is Andrew Rea a chef no I'm
not and I say that as often as possible
because people will say yes chef or
they'll be like Thank You chef er you
know chef Andrew Rea in town this week
or whatever and I am NOT a chef my work
in restaurants has been limited to a
dessert plate er at a restaurant in
Brooklyn called the chocolate room and
as a server at a place in Rochester and
a crepe maker and a place called simply
crepes in Rochester so no I'm not a chef
I'm an enthusiastic home cook and I want
to make that distinction for two very
important reasons first off because I
haven't earned that title people who are
chefs you know put in their hours in
insane work conditions that I've never
had to endure and also because I am a
home cook and I want people to see what
I do and think of this doofus can do it
shortly I can do it so I want people to
know that I am a home cook I've never
had any formal training anything like
that is Andrew Rea married no I'm not I
was for a little bit and not anymore and
I'm not gonna go any deeper into that
that I've respect all those involved hi
I am no longer married but I am attached
to a lovely woman named Jess is Andrew
Rea a violinist you guys have a violin
do you want to find out you know violin
do you is it true just getting into some
like theoretical physics here is Andrew
raised zero yes question mark oh this is
actually cool III I'm dying to get a
zero tattoo on my neck we're lucky
Stanfield has his number three just
because he has is there and he's the
hottest human being alive I want to get
one in the same spot that's a zero
because I think zero is the most
fascinating concept there was no symbol
for zero in European culture for
hundreds of thousands of years I don't
know the exact figures don't quote me on
that but zero there was no symbol for it
because it represents the abyss it
represents the absence of anything which
if you are tied up in dogmatic
ideologies or whatever you cannot fathom
the idea
embracing the void is an important
philosophical concept I think so having
a symbol that denotes that it's like not
being afraid of death embracing and
jumping into the void I really like that
concept and so I really want to get a
zero on my neck and I'm just hoping it
doesn't alienate too many of us when I
do something like that
is Andrew brave engine with babish yes I
am next question who is binging with
babish as roommates well so back when I
was starting to make the show
his name was Rashid duro so he is one of
my was his that's still his name is he's
alive he's still living in that
apartment he is one of my oldest and
dearest friends probably the oldest
friend that I have because he was the
first friend that I made when I moved to
a new school
ninth grade he's one of my oldest and
dearest friends we still hang out on the
regular and he is still up in that that
apartment that I was making the show in
previous now I do not have a roommate I
will soon when I move in with Jess how
did Benjen with babish starts quite by
accident and the evidence is in the main
binging with babish is kind of a stupid
name and I picked it arbitrarily after
my reddit handle as a joke I picked my
red handle arbitrarily Oliver babish is
a character from the 8th total episodes
of the West Wing I like naming online
user names after obscure characters from
TV shows for example old reddit user
name of mine was a cam Winston from
Frasier it was he was Frazier's main
antagonist for like two seasons you know
anybody who gets it we're automatically
friends so anybody who gets all over
babish I know you've seen enough West
Wing to have memorized that one
character it's like it's like a litmus
test for who's gonna be your buddy so
it's very clear that I had no intention
of this becoming my career or anything
that I would pursue full-time and it
started when I was just screwing around
in my kitchen I set up a camera and
Parks and Rec was on in the background I
wanted to test that my food photography
skills and Ron and Chris were having a
burger cook-off and I was like what
would that taste like it was like maybe
I should just do that on camera and just
make it as sort of an exercise a
creative exercise now here we are
talking about it I'm Jake you
now we're here talking about it I'm
wired so that's why I named my red a
handle Oliver babish and then I named
the show after my reddit handle because
I was making the show expressly for
reddit I I never intended it for it to
go anywhere else that's that that's no
no it's history now we're talking about
it I'm wired
how binging with babish Jon Favreau I
assume that means how did I like meet
him or like you know how did we get
acquainted I found out when I around
when I had 800,000 or so subscribers
that he was a fan of the show he had
tweeted about me when I when I did the
Cubano sandwich in the pasta aisle olio
he tweeted those those videos and then
when I hits million subscribers he
tweeted congrats on hitting a million
subscribers and when he did that I just
signed with an agency I just signed with
William Morris Endeavor I asked my
agents which was the most exciting
sentence in the world at the time I was
like can you reach out to Jon's people
like I really want to do something with
them he clearly cares about food as a
construct and as a plot device and as a
character in movies and I think he would
appreciate what I do the same day his
team reached out and they said you know
we're making this new cooking show which
turned out to be chef's show on Netflix
we're making this new cooking show would
you like to come by and be on that show
and general intern John will be on your
show I was dancing around my apartment I
was never been so happy in my entire
life meeting him was the single most
exciting and important experience of my
life he gave me advice that I hold dear
to my heart to this day he Shepherd
shepherded me into this wild new world
that I've answered it into where I'm
meeting celebrities and I'm and I'm
making things that are seen by millions
of people he had some words of wisdom
but that it was it was several years ago
it was during the Winter Olympics and
while we were there somebody tagged him
on Instagram they were an Olympic luge
loser they had Ironman on their helmet
and they tagged John in the photo and he
saw it and he brought it over to me and
it's like look at this this is a almost
ten year old movie that affected
somebody to the point where they put it
on their helmet while they're
representing themselves and them in
their country that is the most magic
that the magical thing that I could
imagine
you know happening from one of one of my
films is that it could affect somebody
to that degree this this is what's
special about what we do and first of
all he said what we do he loved us in
the same category which blew my mind and
what he meant was telling stories I'm
doing in a much smaller way to us much
smaller audience but I'm telling stories
and it creates connections and it
creates communities around the things
that you do that it's such a special
experience and it's become the most
important part of what I do and so
that's one of the many pieces of wisdom
that he dropped on me that day and he
just Shepard shepherded me into this new
sort of world and it was a very long
answer to what I hope that question was
about we'll see I would be honored John
to be in the Mandalorians season to call
me you have my number that was he
actually has my number and one time he
called me when I was in the shower and I
came out and I said missed call Jon
Favreau and my brain exploded
how does Benjy with babish cook a steak
really on specific twits that really
depends on the steak is the correct
answer to that question
skirt steak or something thin that needs
high heat you're blasting it with heat
in a pan and that's it you're just
trying to get out of it and and and
keeping it medium you know medium ish on
a NASCAR steak because you can you can
cook it a little bit more you know and
it'll still stay tender and juicy we're
getting the ribeye territory you know
Steakhouse thick steak territory I'm a
big fan of the reverse sear I like it
either way searing and then finishing in
the oven or oven and then finishing in
the pan it's the best way to get
Steakhouse like results and also butter
basting butter baste your steaks for
God's sake almost any steak I would say
you should you should do that that's how
I cook a steak and medium-rare depending
on the steak again but medium-rare did
binging with babish go to culinary
school I did not it's a good question I
am a very avid home enthusiast I've
considered a few times going to culinary
school to amp up my my chops since I
host a cooking show but any skills that
I have you've seen me sharpened
over the years if you go back and watch
some of my videos from four years ago
you're gonna see me do some stuff that I
would not do now and that's because I'm
learning right along with you why does
benjin with babish use kosher salt I'll
tell you why because kosher salt is the
perfect texture for pinching it is it's
the size of the grain really that counts
with table salt you can't pinch it you
have to sprinkle it and it's very salty
because in a teaspoon of table salt you
have much more salt because of how small
the granules are there's a lot more salt
in any given volume being a teaspoon or
a tablespoon then there would be a
teaspoon or a tablespoon of kosher salt
so it's more forgiving in measured
recipes and with seasoning things that
you don't measure like you know you're
just seasoning your eggs or your your
cast you know it's not something you're
saying it's much more forgiving and you
want to do that with your hands you want
to feel how much salt you're putting
into the dish so you can pinch it that's
the great thing about the kosher salt is
you can pinch it you could use sea salt
you could use anything else that you
pinched you to use Maldon flaky salt but
that's more of a finishing salt because
it has texture to it's big and flaky and
crunchy I and most chefs like kosher
salt because it's forgiving you can
pinch it you can feel how much salt is
going into the dish it's an essential
part of like really understanding why
food behaves the way it does is Benjamin
with babish allergic to bananas I don't
know honestly I don't know the only
reason I think I'm allergic to bananas
is because I ate a banana the day before
my wedding and I blew up like a freaking
balloon I'd turned red and I doubled in
size and volume had to drive myself to
the hospital and the only thing I'd
eaten that day was a banana so I've
always assumed it was bananas since then
and the only way to disprove it is to
eat a banana in front of a physician and
have him just sitting there with the
with the with the epinephrine just
waiting to inject me and it's just too
scary of an experience and I don't care
enough about bananas to to go through
that so we'll say thank you internet so
much for these awesome and sometimes
befuddling questions thank you wired for
having me and keep cooking I will if you
will